في تطور اخر اجر الرئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو مباحثات في
القدس مع مستشار الامن القومي
في رام الله مساء اليوم من القدس ينضم
الينا مراسل الجزيره الياس كرام استقبل
صوليفان من رئيس الوزراء الجديد لكن ايضا
هنالك مصادر امريكيه تتحدث عن لهجه شديده
من قبل الامريكان فيما يتعلق بحل الدوله
تين همم ما الذي تسرب عما يمكن ان يقوله
الطالب للاسرائيليين
بالفعل وهي زياره على قدر كبير من الاهميه
في توقيتها لاسيما ان سلفا هو اول وارفع
شخصيه سياسيه في الاداره الامريكيه تصل
الى اسرائيل بعد تشكيل الحكومه الجديده في
اسرائيل التي توصف بالاكثر تطرفا في تاريخ
اسرائيل ولان هذه الزياره تاتي واسطه
تاكيدات من اطراف امريكيه موثوقه تؤكد ان
سلفا يحمل الى اسرائيل رساله شديده اللهجه
من الاداره الامريكيه تحث الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده عن الامتناع عن
القيام باي خطوات او اجراءات احاديه
الجانب من شانها ان تقضي على رؤيه حاله
دولتين التي ترى فيه الاداره الامريكيه
الحل الامثل من اجل حل القضيه الفلسطينيه
والنزاع الفلسطيني
الاسرائيلي ومنعي اي اجراءات او خطوات من
جانب اسرائيل من شانها ان تقود السلطه
الفلسطينيه اا في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
وتحديدا في رام الله هذه هي الرساله التي
تسربت واكدتها مصادر امريكيه موثوقه
للغايه اا لكن واضح بانه عندما خرج الضيف
والمضيف الى الاعلام كانت اللهجه اكثر
دبلوماسيه واكثر وديه وتحدث الطرفان عن
مساعي المشتركه للاداره الامريكيه واشنطن
ولتل ابيب من اجل المضيء قدمان في عمليه
السلام واجراءات السلام وهذا الكلام الذي
نسمعه ويتردد في كل زياره لضيف امريكي
وهذا ما شدد عليه ايضا
امام الاعلان في رساله مقتدمه اشار فيها
الى التزام الاداره الامريكيه بامر
اسرائيل مؤكدا على ان هذه هي هذا موقف
تاريخيا ثابت لنستمع الى ما قاله سوليفان
في هذا السياق
الرئيس سبايدر مان
وعميق تجاه دوله اسرائيل والتزام الولايات
المتحده صلب وقوي يقوم على القيم والتاريخ
والتحديات المشتركه لدينا كثير من الفرص
والتحديات التي يمكننا التعاون والعمل معا
بشانها
في هذا السياق ابن يمينه رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي اشار في سياق لقائه مع سلفا
وقال بان اسرائيل لن تقبل ما سماه الهجوم
الدبلوماسي للفلسطينيين على اسرائيل في
المحافل الدوليه وان اسرائيل سوف ترد على
ذلك نشرون الى ان الدبلوماسيه الامريكيه
نجحت قبيله هذه الزياره في تجميد عطاء او
على الاقل ايام معدوده مناقشه عطاء لمياء
مئه واحده استيطانيه جديده هنا في مستوطنه
التي نقف امامها في قلب حي جبل المكبر في
القدس المحتله لكي لا يعيقه هذا الاجراء
على صفوه هذه الزياره كما حدث في عام 2010
عندما قامت اسرائيل بنشره عطاء لبناء 16
اسرائيل بصفته نائبا للرئيس اوباما على
المقلب الفلسطيني من الواضح بان جاكسون
سوف يتوجه مع بعض قليل الرئيس الفلسطيني
محمود عباس في مقر المقاطعه في رام الله
وهناك سوف يستمع ايضا من الجانب الفلسطيني
عن المخاوف التي تعتري الفلسطينيين في ظل
التصعيد الاسرائيلي الحاصل منذ نحو عام في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله الجانب
الفلسطيني اكد انه س- يقولوا لسيلوفان ان
على الاداره الامريكيه ان تتخذ الا تكتفي
فقط بالاقوال بل ان تفعل وتعمل مع الجانب
الاسرائيلي على وقف هذا التصعيد الحاصل في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله والالتزام
بقرارات قرارات الشرعيه الدوليه في ما
يتعلق بالقضيه الفلسطينيه
من القدس شكرا جزيلا